and Raven
let's secret to any movie and you can
make it about any topic and as long as
you can heck the audience invested and
whatever it is that you're trying to
convey I believe it could be as abstract
as a piece of pavement in the San
Fernando Valley and make it interesting
if you have interesting people and an
interesting angle and something that
people begin to care about in the case
of 16 right the visuals and the music
and some of the stories bring it to life
but money I was going to people at the
airport primarily because I felt they'd
have they'd get it they'd have the
interest in it they'd want to support it
they'd love to see this movie memorial
or the airport memorialized in the way
that I intended and I thought they're
the people had the money they had the
means certainly the people I was
approaching but it was not easy at all
because they're like okay you want this
much money you want to make a movie
about Van Nuys Airport but really who is
going to ever see this film who is
really genuinely going to be interested
in a movie about the Van Nuys Airport
and I'm sure anyone listening to this is
probably questioning the same thing
finally when I made a sample of my
product the prototype this is some of
the best advice that I can relay but
they're not investors in the people that
you want to support your film aren't
filmmakers probably and they're also not
visionaries they can't see a piece of
paper and understand exactly what you're
doing and it isn't an indication of your
vision either or your talent or what the
experience of a motion picture is when
story music and visuals come together so
you show that sample and they're going
to get it